chris young music i hear this number
getting tossed around
2.5 billion streams
2.5 billion streams like when you hear a
number like that can you even
fathom the number like that yeah man
i mean kind of yeah i i think me as a
kid
if you ever told me anything like that
through a number that big out at me that
people were listening my music
i would be a little taken aback and i
still am it's
pretty awesome yeah do you still have
the moments that are like pinch me
moments
that's like when you hear a number like
that that's like what yeah and i got
actually my label surprised me not too
long ago uh with the with a plaque when
it crossed 2 billion
and i was just like did they mistype
this at first like i
had that like one moment of i don't
think it is it okay cool
yeah where do you celebrate where do you
put a plaque like that that one won my
house
okay no no not that bad
i put like a banner above my house 2.5
billion
i feel like i've been really lucky i've
been around for a long time i had a lot
of love songs in my career and then
something
recent like the song drowning is just
really really personal
and has become personal to a lot of
other people you know i've had a lot of
people come up and tell me
hey i lost my dad or this song reminds
me of a friend that i lost and
being able to impact somebody's life
with music like that is just really
special yeah
how hard is it going to be to sing that
on tour soon on
a nightly basis uh you know what it's
actually not hard to sing on tour i
haven't broken down once
other than when i played it at the opry
and i have no idea why
it was one of the first times i played
the song and like i could probably count
on
both hands how many times i've cried in
my life and i felt like a really big
idiot but it was
it was a really cool moment and it just
really speaks to how much this song
means to me wrote it about a friend of
mine that passed away unexpectedly
how do you feel mature life because
you've been doing this for a bit you
know what i'm i'm lucky and that now
i've gotten to the point where
i was just talking before we went on
camera about my dog i could take my dog
with me
right yeah so i you know back in the day
it was like we had
you know 12 bunks and we had 14 people
on a bus right and it's just uh
in a place now where that's nice upgrade
now yeah just a little just a little
dog's name's porter right yeah porter
the dog and he has an instagram account
now which is like blown up
he did it right he has like 70 000
followers on instagram and
one of my friends the other day was like
how the hell did you do that i was like
it wasn't me it's just people wanted to
go look at my dog
he's a cute dog
the other song county big enough i love
this song with lauren
yeah yeah man this one's kind of taken a
life of its own i wrote that song
with a couple of my buddies and actually
shea mooney from dana shane oh okay
and uh on the original version i have
this somewhere just for blackmail
purposes i have
shea singing the girl oh yeah
[Music]
the song seems like it's about a
breakout that's how i interpret the song
yes
i know i found it interesting that
you're someone who said like you don't
want to talk about your personal life
publicly which i totally respect that
but that's kind of a rare thing for
country music artists to
do that yeah i don't i don't know if
it's
the way to go for everybody but for me
i'm i'm like i don't mind talking about
things that i do when i'm off and giving
people a glimpse into my life and
talking about things that i enjoy and
talking about things other than just
music even though that dominates my life
most of the time
but yeah i just keep my private life
private yeah you have to draw that line
it's not right
that's mine keep you yeah